it is october 2nd 2021 so time for
another monthly update video i'll tell
you what we did during september that
you might have missed and what we've got
coming up in october i always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
and they are indeed big things this time
around
next saturday a week from today we have
the big event the international stoicon
conference all of you are invited if you
don't have your ticket already you can
find the link below in the video
description i'll talk more about that in
the october time also coming up in
october towards the end of the month is
another international
event but it goes on for a week stoic
week and this year we also have stoic
week for students so modern stoicism is
kicking out all the
the stops this this month this is the
season of stoicism again more about that
in october
and
on a personal note some of you may be
interested this is big thing number
three i have all my class assignments
for
spring 2022 and i'll tell you about that
it's quite nice quite interesting
and i will tell you all about that in
just a little bit
all right what went on in september you
may have seen some of the pictures of me
taking walks i got to do more of that
got to the gym regularly was teaching my
classes i have three classes this
semester which is considerably less than
previous semesters because i'm not
teaching at milwaukee area technical
college as a matter of fact it may be
done with them all together
and a lot of events we had my usual
online ama that's ask me anything our
hegel sessions uh for worlds of
speculative fiction i did stannis law
lem and i concentrated on solaris but
also talked about his his work more
generally this is a big year for
stanislaus lem the the polish government
declared it the year of lem and uh
september was also the anniversary so
that's quite important
we did the wisdom for life show two new
show episodes and we switched to a
different show time that i'll talk more
about
later we had our classic metal class
which i don't have the video out for yet
but you can see pretty soon scott and i
talking about metal cover songs um i
also did the first presentation of the
stoicon season
at stoicon x norway i was the first
person up the video and also the
transcript of that are available i'll
put those links below what else uh did a
radio interview with riverwest radio
about stoicism and philosophy that you
can access worldwide online and i did
two
well i did several podcasts not all of
them have come out the ones that did
come out were the lifeblood podcast
talking about critical thinking and how
to apply it and the existential stoic
podcast the name and title of that kind
of gives you an idea what we talked
about
i shot a lot of videos i got
five half hour hegel videos released to
my patreon supporters released some of
the older ones to other people i got one
book review video done a little bit less
than i had planned to but that's at
least one i did a sadler story about
playing soccer i did a caption contest
that went quite well and i did two
unboxing videos i didn't mean to do two
unboxing videos but you know margaret
graver's book came and then this giant
35 pound box of books came as well there
are videos for each of the events like
the ama i i should have mentioned my
live readings from my book
reason fulfilled by revelation i've been
continuing on with that and i've been
getting into the actual translations
uh what else a lot of ursula k le guin
videos on a wizard of earth see the
first of her six earth sea books i am
teaching a class on that this semester
so those are for my students but they're
also for you and i'm going to be rolling
out a lot more about you know one about
five times as much right we've got one
book completely finished i'll be rolling
out a lot more of those as well
in the sadler's lectures podcast i
finished out the series on aleister
mcintyre's after virtue chapter 14
and started in on jon stewart mills on
liberty there were quite a few
podcast episodes in that and then i
started doing some more sadler shorts
because people seem to really like those
those are those three to five minute
video or not videos podcasts where i
start out saying pascal says in this
text and then i explain it a little bit
how it has ramifications for our life
what else you know um
i you know i'm in good health uh my
family has had a couple
medical issues
uh
you know
my uh daughter had a contusion on her
her the bone of her foot
and uh you know other other family
things going on you know but hope
luckily nobody's really in bad shape so
that's that's nice to say and uh i've
really been enjoying you know
my my classes teaching them the students
are
motivated and interested and that's uh
that's probably enough for september
oh i'll mention one other thing
lots and lots and lots of back end stuff
on getting you know
stoic weak and the big stoic on which i
am one of the co-organizers for and i'm
going to be the mc for
getting all of that up and ready but
more about that in just a moment
all right so october is going to be a
pretty pretty packed month
we actually don't begin with stowacon
but we'll be talking about that in a
moment on the sixth i'll be doing a
radio interview with my wife and partner
andy shaka on riverwest radio which you
can listen to live all across the world
just by going to their website if you're
in the milwaukee area 104.1 fm
you can listen to it on the actual radio
but most people will be listening on the
internet we are going to be talking
about stoicon stoicism and some of the
other things that were involved in then
on the 9th the big event stoicon 2021
it's online anybody can join you just
got to get a ticket and you can get a
ticket just by making a donation for
the price of not even a cup of coffee
you can participate in an entire day of
events with great speakers
panels a workshop and we've got a
keynote address by nancy sherman
those who are familiar with you know
virtue ethics stoicism aristotelianism
and military ethics will know that name
she is a great speaker
and so we've got this really cool online
event lined up um again you the the
website for the tickets is below you can
check out the uh entire schedule
and see whether you want to do it you've
got to get a ticket before the event
starts though so if you want to join in
on it then on the 13th uh the following
week at 5 00 p.m i'll have my
hegel q a and discussion session open to
the public anybody who wants to join in
talk about hegel german idealism
philosophy in general i will be there on
the 16th we'll be having the ama that is
ask me anything session online so if
you've got questions for me that's the
place to bring them not not as you know
irrelevant comments on videos show up
for that session and you'll get an
answer if you get in early enough
because the questions pile up
on the 23rd
that's another saturday we at 12 p.m
noon all these times by the way are
central time classic metal class scott
chirulli and i have already got a topic
in mind and lined up and we're going to
be
going into that
it's it's really
i i haven't come up with a catchy title
for it but it's
how did bands get access to their fans
through video before mtv
came on the scene turns out there was an
entire ecosystem of shows and videos and
things like that so we're going to talk
about that pre-mtv and we're going to
talk about the impact that mtv had on
the metal scene as it was developing
also on the 23rd at 2 pm philosophy chat
that's a more intimate session for my
patreon supporters at a particular level
on the 30th we'll finally get around to
doing another political theory and
practice discussion about how they're in
the united states we don't really have
systems for very important things
federalism and localism have created a
very interesting and perplexing
uh
let's call it condition for us that i
think a lot of people in other countries
don't really know that much about and
and this provides us with an answer to
well why can't you fix x
um so we'll talk about that
um on the
uh
18th through the 24th it's stoic week
and so you're probably
going to want to get ready for that
that's a monday through a sunday free to
anybody who wants to participate every
year thousands of people live like a
stoic for a week reading some morning
and evening reading and meditations
listening to some guided meditations
doing some practices talking with each
other in an online class so that's a big
thing as well
usually it follows right after stoicon
but this time we spaced them out a
little bit
every saturday you can listen to the
wisdom for life radio show
on riverwest radio at 5 00 pm central
time
we do new shows every other week so the
you know if you're listening to it at a
a an off week it'll be an old
pre-recorded show but it's always
interesting stuff
there is the milwaukee stoic fellowship
as well we're kind of reconfiguring that
so stay tuned for that
i think that's it for the events for the
month i am also going to be like pretty
preoccupied with my online classes i'm
teaching
two for milwaukee institute of art and
design one for carthage college a
business ethics for them an ethics for
artisan designer designers and the
leguin class for
milwaukee institute of art and design
what else you know
videos i
i'm i've got some good steam going with
hegel you know going through the
phenomenology of spirit and so i'm going
to keep grinding away at this with the
half hour hegel project maybe get six
videos done this month
i'm going to be doing some more book
review videos these are long overdue
people give me books thinking that they
will get reviewed and really i i need to
get around to doing it
we'll do some more fun stuff as well
like sandler stories and caption
contests if i've got something good to
unbox i will unbox it event videos of
course and by the way in the modern
stoicism channel you'll see a lot of
other stuff coming out not just in my
main youtube channel but modern stoicism
i've been doing a lot of video editing
of the interviews that we're doing with
the speakers and workshop providers
and what else you're going to see a lot
of ursula k le guin specifically on the
tombs of ottuan her second novel but
probably
well maybe some stuff on the farthest
shore the third in the original earth
sea trilogy
which grew to be six books podcast work
i'm going to keep doing some more shorts
and then i'm going to do some tolstoy
i've got a few podcast episodes on him
to edit on what is art then we're going
to start doing some lev shestoff and
some friedrich nietzsche getting ready
for the classes that i'm going to be
teaching
next semester so let me tell you about
that before we close out it was one of
the three big things right
so carthage college i am going to be
teaching a medieval philosophy class
which will be a lot of fun i haven't
gotten to teach that for a long time i
already have a few thinkers in mind
obviously the three a's augustine anselm
aquinas but you know boethius is going
to be in there as well i might do uh
john scottis erigini uh regina um he's
somebody who who i i haven't taught
before but i've read you know since i
was an undergraduate and i think would
be kind of cool
and then we'll see who else we can get
in there maybe some bonaventure you know
as a contemporary of thomas
maybe actually reading some stuff about
saint francis along with bonaventure you
know from the little flowers it's not
just a medieval philosophy but a
medieval thought class i was actually
thinking about um having some other
stuff like on the seven deadly sins like
gregory on moralia and job or or the
psychomachia
anyway we'll see i'll i'll be writing
more about what i'm doing with that so
that's one class i'm teaching next
semester
another class is my existentialist
philosophy in literature which has
become a staple for me at milwaukee
institute of art and design that'll be
either the third or fourth time around
that i've taught the class and that is a
lot of fun that's an area that i'm
particularly interested in and then i'll
be doing another religions of the world
class which is a class that i used to
teach every semester in some of my
former jobs and i i think it's a great
class to do it's a lot of fun with art
majors because we get to look at
architecture and art and ritual and all
that sort of stuff so
that is what is on the horizon once
again let me remind you if you don't
have a ticket for stoicon and you want
to go october 9th online event open to
everybody
you know it's the most inexpensive uh
major international conference i think
you'll ever find we don't we wanted to
make it as
easy for anybody to attend as possible
if you have any interest at all in
stoicism you probably want to come to
this event so
a lot to look forward to and i i look
forward myself to seeing you in the
online events crossing paths virtually
and you know if you're here in the
milwaukee area maybe i'll see you as i
take my long walks through the downtown
and menominee valley
you